Електробус Е-19 українського виробництва вдвічі дорожчий за дизельний автобус,
але в експлуатації щонайменше у 10 разів дешевший.
Тож різниця вартості компенсується за 5 років,
запевняє виробник Е-19 львівський "Електрон".
Вартість базового електробуса 9 мільйонів гривень.
А вартість базового дизельного автобуса, який купують українські міста,
рівно вдвічі менша - чотири з половиною мільйони.
Експлуатаційні витрати на автобуси прораховуються за витратами на пальне та електрику,
а також на технічне обслуговування.
Дизельний автобус потребує пального в середньому надві з половиною тисячі гривень щодоби.
Тоді як електробус має підзарядитися електроенергією лише на 200 гривень.
Дизельні автобуси мають проходити ТО, яке передбачає заміну різних мастил і фільтрів.
В середньому це може коштувати5 тисячгривень щомісяця.
А технічне обслуговування електробуса значно простіше.
Раз на рік чи два треба лише міняти мастило в редукторі.
І це коштує лише3 тисячі гривень.
Акумуляторна батарея потребує заміни елементів у разі нормального функціонування
лише років через 5.
За умови, якщо автобуси працюють 24 доби усі 12 місяців,
то за перші п'ять років експлуатаційні витрати становлять
приблизно чотири мільйони гривень для дизельного автобуса і лише 320 тисяч для електробуса.
Тобто, приблизно у 12 разів менше.
За 5 років електробус може покрити різницю вартості порівняно з дизелем
за рахунок значно менших експлуатаційних витрат.
Але це ідеальний варіант.
Реально ж через 6 років, враховуючи коливання цін на енергоресурси і курс долара.
Чіткі розрахунки щодо використання електробусів замість "дизелів"
українські міста лише почали робити.
Головним нез'ясованим до кінця фактором є реальна тривалість життя акумуляторної батареї,
і витратина можливі проблеми з нею.
В Україні є поки один електробус Е-19,
і він експлуатується у Львові лише три роки.